the number one question that i get right
now
on this channel is hey i'm thinking
about starting a business what market
should i go after for those who don't
know me my name is oxford mosey i own
acquisition.com we do about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you so
when we look at portfolio companies and
we're trying to figure out what markets
we want to go after because we know just
like warren buffett said if you have a
good entrepreneur and a bad market the
market wins and if you've got a bad
entrepreneur and a good market the
market wins all right so the market that
you pick a lot of times will have a huge
determination on the level of success
that you have right it is far more
important to pick the right boat than
how hard you row those are warren
buffett quotes you can take those to the
bank so top five industry i would be
pursuing in 201 21 2022 um that are
coming up all right the first one um and
believe that this is going to be
unsurprising to you is all things that
are associated with crypto so nfts d5
web 3.0 all the things that come as
downstream ramifications of this uh new
technology all right it's booming um and
there's a lot of really cool
applications that are going to come as a
result of this so if you know this
industry then that would be something
that i would be looking at because even
if you're okay you will be a player in a
massively growing industry so you'll
have a huge tailwind behind you the
second believe it or not is cannabis
right it's still trusted and the reason
i also like it is that it's relatively
recession proof right actually it's a
pro recession thing when recessions
happen alcohol and drug use goes up so
this is something that's still like the
market's so big it still hasn't been
conquered yet there's still tons of
growth to happen there there's still
people it's just becoming mainstream it
still hasn't been completely you know
decriminalized in all the states etc and
so cannabis would be something that i
would be looking at for types of
businesses that i would be looking at
building the next one
is e-learning so obviously this is a big
favorite of mine
and that's because i believe and you've
probably heard me say this many times on
the channel i think that formal
education um has failed many of us it is
a it is an antiquated system that is
built on general knowledge rather than
specific knowledge and right now people
want specific skills that they can use
in the marketplace to make more money
and so the e-learning industry is
becoming increasingly fragmented i don't
think that trend will decrease i think
will only increase in its fragmentation
it will be it'll have more silos and
more verticals with excellent teachers
at the top of them teaching very niche
down skills and so i think that if you
have a niche skill the e-learning uh
marketplace it's set in general is
something that i would be looking at uh
investing in uh my time and effort and
money etc all right and i walk this talk
that's what we do with acquisition.com
we invest in these types of businesses
all right
the the fourth and this is a huge one is
remote living all right so remote living
is everything that touches the
consequence of the huge push of remote
so more people are moving out of cities
they're moving to have more space
they're having at-home offices this
thing that i'm recording on is a mobile
studio right like if you're a
photographer build mobile studios tons
of people want to be able to travel they
want to they want to have studios from
home tons and tons of business to be had
there you don't even have to market
there's so much demand for this type of
stuff uh i mean and there's so many
downstreams of that that's why zoom blew
up um you know like uh there's just
there's so many things with with with
remote living the reason that home home
decorations and home improvements has
been booming is because people are
spending more time at home so that's why
people want bigger houses that's why
they're spending like all of this stuff
as a consequence of this trend which i
don't think is going to decrease right
and then finally you could consider this
maybe a a spin-off of the one above but
i felt like it was different enough
that it deserved its own thing which is
warehousing logistics there is more need
for shipping and stuff to be stored now
than ever before and that trend will
only increase as people want to stay at
home right they want stuff shipped to
them and the demand for people to be
lazy is very very high our brains are
wired to do as little effort as humanly
possible and so anything that i see that
that works in a trend of delivering
something to someone faster with the
least amount of effort uh and this is
the value equation right high perceived
likelihood and a dream outcome which is
they just click something and it shows
up those are things that i would be
investing in because i believe that they
will be the things that outperform the
marketplace as well and so if you can
get into a market that has a tailwind
then you're also going to make the most
money and so as a reminder for those who
are new to the channel there are four
things that we look at in every market
all right number one
is is the market growing
number two
are the people easy to target
number three
is there a need for it are people in
pain right do they not like the way
things are currently this is a smiley
face sorry there you go uh do they not
like the way things currently are and
they have pain to be solved and finally
finally
do they have purchasing power and so i
would look at one of these as the big
buckets that that exist and then you
find one or two steps down from this
bucket you zero in on your niche that
you can capture that is in this growing
marketplace and you will have the chips
stacked in your favor in terms of
getting
investment funding in terms of uh
the amount of demand that will that will
happen simply based on the fact that
more people want this than there are
suppliers of it and this is a simple
supply and demand curve and we prefer to
be on the things that have more demand
and less supply then more supply and
less demand alright and that is uh how i
analyze this in terms of the things that
i'm looking at that i think are going to
be good big trends that that you can hop
on if you're thinking about investing
your time and effort into starting a new
business so anyways mosey nation lots of
love keep being awesome and i'll see you
guys next video bye